when you're talking you need to be able
to achieve two things the one thing you
need to be able to do is you need to be
able to achieve safety and that is a
basically people feel respected they
feel that they're being respected and
they feel that their needs are being
respected that's the one thing that has
got to happen and if that doesn't happen
this conversation is not going to work
as well at all
I'm joined by Tim Harkness Tim welcome
to the show thank you very much Chris
nice to be here
pleasure to have you here an expert
guide to mastering difficult
conversations has there ever been a more
appropriate time to work out how to have
difficult conversations than right now
you know I I wrote the book and just
there's one line in the book that refers
to the the pandemic and it's the last
it's the last revision that was made to
the the manuscript and I thought to
myself as the lockdown started is the
book relevant still because it just
seemed that we had this all-encompassing
issue that we all needed to pay
attention to and then of course you know
the the complexity of the lockdown
emerged and then the black lives matter
protest began as well and suddenly I
thought to myself actually yes you know
I think this notion and and you know not
even to make a claim for my book but
just to make a claim for talking just to
make a claim for communication I think
this is something that we need globally
and yeah absolutely it's been reinforced
in the last couple of months you were
you had a little bit of divination
clairvoyant foresight perhaps there
about just how much it was needed well
you know I mean obviously we we've been
dealing with bricks at for years you
know and and I think people have been
this is growing economic inequality that
I think has been a concern for people
and and that's just at the political
level you know and then at the at the
personal level or the professional level
I mean one of the things that the
lockdown has thrown up has been what I
read this book and it calls it domestic
bargaining and it's basically who does
the vacuuming but you know there's this
whole kind of field of study around it
but that's a body of work now oh yes yes
absolutely
and and you know that the thing is I
mean just think how much it affects all
of us well I don't know if it affects
you but it's in my house me mean my
house may have got every other Thursday
we get the Marigold yellow glow
last we throw the tunes on and he'd look
at he does the bathroom in the living
room and I do really the kitchen and
downstairs and then it's done and that's
it once every two weeks okay so you go
frustrated quality that that that's your
it's like absolutely equality of outcome
and equality of opportunity yet equal
access to the over equal access to the
okay yeah so that's your method and
that's what works it's not everybody
goes with that by the way you know
there's more complex discussions can
emerge I want to know if you're
listening and you've got a very
convoluted way that you and the people
that you live with have partitioned
their housework
throughout locked out and I want you to
tell me what the most complicated ways
are that that's happened cuz this sounds
I found out um my friend's girlfriend
has a very complex way of keeping the
house clean
apparently there's there's a number of
books there are all systematic programs
of how you clean your house it's like if
you took David Allen's getting things
done framework for productivity but
applies it to housework and it's it's so
sophisticated honest bro I was just like
there's there's just underworld that I
totally didn't realize and I was just
living in this different different place
okay so we've we've kind of got
ourselves framed here that we do need to
have conversations and I think at the
moment it's precisely the things that we
need to talk about that we're struggling
to talk about we have quite a lot of
performative communication going on at
the moment it's difficult to work out
who the bad actors are and who the ones
that are just saying something out of
fear or signaling or any one of a number
of different things you're so high level
what is the purpose of communication and
why do we need to learn how to talk yeah
well you know that's rule one is agree
what you're talking for so you know that
that question what is the purpose of
communication we have different
objectives and we run into problems when
two people each have their own agenda in
a conversation it's much easier when we
both want the same thing
so you know just to list some objectives
one kind of conversation is a listening
conversation so you know I get home at
the end of the day and I said to my
partner honey how was your day and
that's a pure listening conversation
because my partner knows about her day
and I don't so you know that that's kind
of point number one is it's just about
information transfer on the other hand
if you're a dentist tonight you know
come and visit you you've got the
information I don't and I just want to
listen so that's one kind of
conversation but you can run into
problems because the one problem could
be I don't realize what I don't know the
second kind of problem is when my ego
gets involved and you start telling me
there's some kind of issue with my teeth
and I go what are you telling me I don't
know how to look after my teeth and then
I stopped listening because there's this
kind of ego problem that that's been
invoked so that's the one kind of
conversations and listening conversation
and you get another kind of conversation
which is an emotional conversation where
you know you and I meet up and and you
said to me you know how's it going and I
stay you know I've been having a tough
time and I start to share my emotions
with you and an emotional conversation
has all the characteristics of a
listening conversation but it's got one
more and that is that if we're having a
listening conversation at some point
when I'm listening I can go okay now I
got it I understand
which obviously you can't do an
emotional conversation you know that
there's no point that doesn't work so
you know that that's another kind of
conversation there's a third kind of
conversation which is a values
conversation where we we evaluate things
was this a good football match or not
and you know is is is immigration
genuinely a problem and black lives
matter that that's a values conversation
it's a it's a conversation about what is
important to us and then once you've had
the values conversation things start to
get again you can add a level of
complexity on top of that and you can
to have a fairness conversation which is
what's fair so even at the the personal
level these are crucial conversations
that we have now you know in your
housework system you've got a totally
fair because you've got complete
equality you know which is you you
dedicate the same amount of effort in
the same amount of time and then no
problems there so you've got it worked
out but not everybody uses equality as a
basis for fairness
some people use deserve which is I had a
really tough day I deserve some time off
once you started introducing that
element or once you start introducing
the element of because that could be
deserve I had a really tough day you
know I had a very stressful meeting only
lasted for 30 minutes but it was so
stressful that I contact you you know
and you know I promise you that line has
been used you could have had a tough
podcast you know you never know maybe
the girl is no good so that's another
complicating element and and a third
complicating element is and that
sometimes fairness is about what we need
and you know this is where to be frank
some of the some of the the hustle
bargaining arguments in what I'm
supposed to say negotiations
negotiations in our house crop up is
that we may have different needs in
terms of how how clean we need to carpet
to be and so so on that basis if I don't
need the carpet to be quite as clean as
what my partner needs it to be then why
should we have equal effort in terms of
achieving something that we don't
equally need so you know and and and I
mean obviously and not to take anything
away from these household bargaining
conversations because they're important
and we all have to do them so that this
is a major issue if the household
bargaining people take error with this
podcast given the last 200 episodes that
we've put out of we've had a porn star
on here we
oK we've you know if that's the thing
alright people sit up and go you know
what Chris had this South African fella
and he would've bad-mouthing the way
that people organized the housekeeping
if that's me went too far I'll be
surprised yet I can talk about porn but
don't you [ __ ] talk about the [ __ ]
you mean well you never know I wouldn't
be surprised yeah but but you know
having said that then these same things
apply to our professional conversations
in our political conversations that in
terms of something like immigration
what's fair and how do we distribute
what people need compared to what people
deserve compared to equality or in terms
of you know distribution of wealth you
know we every buddy is talking about the
1% at the moment and how they you know
so much richer than they used to be or
the fact that CEOs now can earn 200
times as much as a base level employer
and their in their employee in their
organization so you know that that's
another kind of conversation is just a
fairness conversation and then another
kind of conversation is a prediction
conversation and this is that you and I
want the same thing but we disagree
about the best course of action to
achieve it so to me in some ways the
bricks of conversation is a prediction
conversation because we all want the
same thing we all want a happy country
we all want people to have jobs we all
want community you know we all want
healthy people and so on but we've just
got different ideas about what's going
to deliver that and I think that the
prediction kind of conversation it's
important to recognize because often
we're not actually that different
because we do actually want the same
thing it's more like a technical thing
of well how do we achieve that
so you know those are some conversations
and then the kind of master conversation
and this is the one that I really want a
champion is the conversation where we
talk about talking so you know this is
what you and I doing now we're having a
conversation about conversations and
this is an important conversation I
think for everybody when you get stuck
in one of the previous five
conversations you need to be able to
bail out of that conversation going to
hang on whether it this isn't working
let's start talking about talking they
start talking about this conversation
and really that's what the book is
designed to do is kind of equip people
with the skills to to have that
conversation where you're talking about
talking each of those different
categories of conversation that you've
just come up with they're they require a
different mindset a different skillset
yeah and and you know that that that's
actually just today it's an article I've
been working on is which of the rules
apply particularly to those different
kinds of conversations so you know some
of the rules so broadly when when you're
talking you need to be able to achieve
two things the one thing you need to be
able to do is you need to be able to
achieve safety and that is a basically
people feel respected they feel that
they're being respected and they feel
that they need to being respected that's
the one thing that has got to happen and
if that doesn't happen the conversation
is not going to work as well at all the
second thing that you've got to be able
to achieve is that there's got to be
some kind of journey towards the truth
there's got to be some kind of shared
understanding of the worlds and the
conversations got to be effective and
the skills that you use for each of
those now a conversation cannot be safe
unless it's effective you know you and I
can have all the respect we like for
each other and you know we have in in
the world for each other but if we see
the world in completely different ways
you know if you think the world is round
and I think the world is flat
unless we've made some sort of progress
to getting closer to a shared
understanding the world we've been
wasting our time and it's unlikely that
we're going to be able to maintain full
respect for each other given that we've
got such a kind of significantly
different view of the world but at the
same time we can't have an effective
conversation unless it's a safe
conversation so we can't start bombing
each other with facts and logic and you
know arguments and this we actually both
feel respected and and you know kind of
honored by the other person yeah it
starts it devolves into either a debate
which is the sort of formal version of a
conversation which you identify in the
book or I guess a slanging match which I
don't know if that technically exists in
the book
but yeah but a very real thing oh
absolutely yeah that's the the unspoken
type of conversation that that's not in
there yeah it's um those two things the
effectiveness slash kind of the namaste
one plus one equals three in this
conversation we both go away with more
wisdom than we came in with it yeah the
effectiveness slash truth and the safety
yes I am seeing almost every
conversation on the internet qualify
neither of those of those
characteristics like people are going
out of their way to make conversations
as unsafe as possible to try and show as
little respect you you talk about the
retort and the soundbite in the book as
well and both of those are really
fascinating the way that a retort is a
put-down designed to almost interrupt
the flow of a conversation and that the
one safety net that you used to have in
a flowing conversation was that you
needed to have a particular degree of
spontaneous creativity in order to be
able to do a you know a zinger the
neatly old knee-slapper in a debate like
you have to wear ads now that a lot of
our conversations are mediated by the
internet you got five minutes you can
set you may go he thinks
this guy this guy just said that that my
podcast [ __ ] what can I do what can I
call our court Colin bald Colin bought
you yeah he's bald you know it's a good
one yeah so you can kind of do this and
um yeah it seems like everything at the
moment is gearing us as a society as a
community toward having worse types of
conversations and I really do feel so
blessed to find long-form conversations
enjoyable because if I didn't I worry
because I listen to us consume a lot of
content Joe Rogan Sam Harris special
hero etc etc yeah if I didn't enjoy that
the only things that I would be
consuming I like the 15 second story you
know there isn't to me hopefully for the
listeners as well these sorts of
conversations are like that the tonics
you know that are calming that the
antidote to the venom in a way that
people are seeing look yes it's slower
yes it's more pedestrian yes you have to
do a little bit of work to actually get
some of it but that's the point it's
like a mental gymnasium for yourself
right as opposed to it just being look
at this 280 character and put down that
sin filled with emojis and like has a
gif attached to it like that's not you
know summer I mean like when that's the
yeah that time that's very interesting
and and I hadn't thought of that you
know I hadn't thought of the difference
between the long form and you know the
tweet or something like that but yeah
that makes sense
I think being just being around that a
lot of the time especially during
lockdown people maybe haven't had a lot
of people to talk to yeah we may be
living on your own or living with one of
the person you don't have tons of people
to talk to so no I think I've I've
talked more to podcast guests don't have
to anybody else ass rats or in an
equivalent way I've probably listened to
Ben Shapiro more than has listened to
any other person um okay what what does
that do to our ability to understand how
to communicate right because really
there's no there's not a whole lot of
difference between me listening to ban
in my ears you know that's all I'm going
around doing I worked it with them and a
listening conversation where I don't
ever speak yes you know I mean so what
does that do to us and how does that how
can that be the antithesis co2 this
short form stuff I think that's yeah and
you know I really like that idea because
I think you know I think sometimes we
can solve problems by reasoning our way
through them and other way other times
we can solve problems just by exposing
ourselves to different things you know
what you're saying is let's just expose
ourselves to more long form and in that
we solve many of the problems that have
emerged you know because of the fast
pace of life and technology and and you
know that this intermittent
communication that in written
communication also you know weird and
and I often think to myself you know
what one of the stories that amazes me
is you know being South African one of
one of the key events in South African
history was the Anglo Zulu war in 1879
and mainly the Battle of asunder one and
then what's famous in this country is
the Battle of Rorke's drift and you know
in in a previous generation they used to
show the movie I think was called Zulu
every Christmas which was the story of
the Battle of you know this was just a
tradition everybody would sit down and
watch this movie again and again and
again and the the battle culminated in a
series of negotiations and you had the
British parties who were literate you
know who came from a literate society
and the zoo negotiation and negotiators
were illiterate there they had no
writing what they did have though was
the ability to memorize the entire
conversation from a single listening so
they would go long they would listen to
a five-hour conversation and they'd go
back to the king and they'd be able to
recite at word for
word and you know you've got this so
this is a society that that at that
point and it's 150 years ago had not
been exposed to technology but had
developed this incredible spoken culture
as a way of adapting for the technology
you know that was letters and notes and
and you know shorthand and what and
whatever else and that it is something
I'm a little aware of it I think having
come from growing up in an African
country is I do think sometimes there
there's a there's a tradition of
conversation that that is quite strong
there's still some echoes of that I
think so you know and and that's not to
say it doesn't exist chair you know in
pubs and and areas where people here get
together and just talk you know and yeah
if if podcasts and long-form
communications are emerging as another
environment where people can do
something that I think is natural to us
you know what what really is better than
just sitting and talking with other
people and it's I spent hundreds of
hours every year doing it for the sheer
joy of it and I have a piece of advice
that listeners will know once a week
every week for 30 minutes at least you
need to sit down with a friend and have
a conversation about something that both
of you are interested in you leave your
phones outside of your room and you will
leave that room feeling like you've just
gone through therapy or a cool gym
session or lutely sauna
yeah there is something incredibly
therapeutic about having a conversation
where it's you and another person
without distractions
hold your each other to intellectual
rigor trying to be as precise as
possible okay yes yeah yeah right yeah
oh hang on you've just said this thing
but two seconds ago you said that thing
I don't think those two things quite
marry you up being genuinely interested
in what the other person has to say and
so much of that stuff you know I didn't
have a foresight for ten rules for
talking in your book but there's a lot
of that which marries up and when you
see someone who
than the research in the literature when
your experience of the world matches
what exists in the literature it kind of
is it really reinforces it in a nice way
yeah a lot of people listening want to
have better conversations what are the
most common errors you see people
working when conversing well I think I'd
I think you the two ways of looking at
that the one way of looking at it is you
can say what kinds of what kinds of
what's conversation styles do people
have so the one way you could break it
down is you could say some people tend
to escalate and so I think an example of
this is someone like Piers Morgan now
you know piers I agree with him strongly
on some issues and I'd disagree with him
strongly on on some issues as well which
is moderate on peers a year it's always
yes or no yes but at least it's mixed
you know at least I don't disagree with
him on everything and cut or agree with
him on everything and but as you say
you're not moderate and the reason why
is that he's not moderate he escalates
he makes a big deal out of things and
and he tends to bring emotion into the
into the topic he sees the world in
quite a black-and-white sort of way and
so I think that's that's an escalator
and escalators can be useful sometimes
you know if if we're having a picnic and
you know that there's a beautiful sunset
and they you know butterflies flying
around in a way we want to be escalating
this we want to be going wow this is
fantastic you know we're having a
wonderful time this is brilliant
on the other hand if we're having a
political argument or if you know if me
and a mate are sitting in a room having
a conversation and I go no I don't think
you've been consistent there what I
don't want to do is escalate because
I've picked up that he's been
inconsistent I don't they want to go you
know what you're inconsistent urological
you're illogical because you lack
intelligence and you lack intelligence
because you have no education and you're
not a good person a bla bla bla and that
would be an escalation and you know it's
it's something that we're all too prone
to so so that's you know that that's
notion number one is the idea of
escalation and and it can it can be a
good thing but it can be inappropriate
as well there's a lot there that people
need to step into their own programming
with regards to their desire to want to
win a conversation yeah yeah because
inevitably by making the other person
look dumb feel silly
embarrassed whatever it might be it's I
guess point for me like that's Chris one
up on the pedestal and Jonathan one down
on the pedestal you know
yeah yeah yeah and you know that comes
back to rule one which is agree what
you're talking for and if I'm going into
a conversation with the aim of willing
the conversation or taking the other
person down a peg
well in some ways fine if that's your
genuine objective but I think that the
problem will like is people don't
realize that that's what they're
pursuing and it's not what they really
want so absolutely you know I'm not
looking to take well
I think most of the time it's not an
explicit aim and it's not the best day
and when it's when it creeps in I think
even if you asked someone yes did you
mean to have an adversarial conversation
there where you made the other person
feel silly in retrospect or beforehand
no but they just get caught up the
signal in does that go over the far side
looking or there's that person at the
table who I want to look the boss is
watching at the table and I want to look
okay so that was the first category
that's what this yes second category
storytellers so you you get some people
who who communicate their view of the
world through stories and I think a
great example of this is Boris Johnson
that he's got this this real neck from
metaphor and he you know when he talks
about the coronaviruses in an invisible
mugger he says we're going to send it
packing when he was critical of Theresa
mayors bricks of negotiations by saying
with that there's a white flag
fluttering as we walk into the meeting
room you know these are very vivid and
and plausible stories that he tells and
obviously sometimes stories are
effective you know as human beings we
relate to stories and and they're a good
way of persuading us sometimes but then
again there's a there's a limitation to
them and in that they lack a real kind
of level of precision and accuracy so
that the problem with the story is that
a story's not verifiable you know just
some I'm flying the white flag well what
on earth does that mean how would we
measure you know how do you measure
whether we flag there is is why is it
slightly cream yeah that's the thing you
know there's just nowhere to tell and
when there's nowhere to tell we've
limited our potential to agree because
as you say a conversation is about
trying to find out the truth it's trying
to find out how the world really is so
what I should be doing in a conversation
well what we should be doing in a
conversation is we're both trying to
work out a fact about the world
I'm not trying to persuade you of my
worldview and you're not trying to
persuade me of your worldview we're both
trying to journey towards an improved
understanding of how the world can be
and that's ultimately how we persuade is
by perceiving what is real and
storytellers compromise on that
potential and then you know just because
p.m. Q's is quite interesting at the
moment you've got what what I would call
an analyst so you've got Kia stahma who
is quite strong on the rigor on the
facts on the detail on the precision and
and he interacts with so that you've got
an analyst interacting with a
storyteller and it kind of makes for
quite good fireworks because you've got
these two very different conversational
approaches now it does mean that they're
really just scoring points of each other
you know the potential for genuine
collaboration and the potential for
actual agreement is fairly low because
you know you've got two such different
approaches and and you know I think we
all kind of relate to analysts you know
if someone's building a bridge or an
aeroplane I want an analyst and you know
to be perfectly honest Johnson no I
don't want a storyteller you know I
don't want war these wings look
fantastic you know they are gonna lift
you up on the wind you know I'm not
wanting that kind of thing I'm wanting
the analyst and to be perfectly honest
you know when it comes to an economic
policy I'm wanting an analyst as well
but being an analyst is not enough
because part of operating in a democracy
is that we need to be bound together you
know we need to have a shared identity
we need to have some sense of a
collective narrative that is meaningful
and important for all of us and that's
where the storytellers come in is that
they can be very good at doing that
so you know once again I think the
analyst is the definite strengths but
then it's not the only solution it's not
super persuasive either is it you know
the fact that Boris Johnson won the most
recent general election by a landslide
as a storyteller what does that tell you
it tells you that people are much more
persuaded by stories than they are by
fact if if facts were what
persuaded most people then the
economists would run the world it would
just be the people that were able to
that macro this and the standard
deviations actually inside the integral
like so if none of that is about that I
love the idea of storytelling increasing
the imprecision within the conversation
as a tool almost as a tool right and I
like the thinking about in myself
sometimes
I only just realizing it now use analogy
as a way to escape being precise with
what I'm saying yet because as you say
as soon as you use an analogy everywhere
the rules of the game are completely out
the window you're not you're no longer
talking about the situation it's an
analogous situation by definition
absolutely absolutely yeah that's a big
one checking checking yourself about yes
am I using this to enhance the
conversation and add Flair and sort of
color or am i doing it to hide myself
from hide away from a deficiency in
rigor and precision about how I'm
actually putting this topic across those
those are really really cool so it we we
got that can we can we try and help the
people listening self diagnose the kind
of conversationalist that they are
they're thinking man's this sound this
sounds good but I don't know I'm a this
person or that person yes
you know I add one more just to to fill
out the sit so the four kinds of
confidence conversationalist so we've
got the we've got the the storyteller
we've got the escalator we've got the
analysts and one more is what I'd say is
the safety first step and the safety
first step is the person who's prepared
to compromise on their own point of view
or on their own needs in order to stop
the conversation getting heated
or breaking down so there comes a point
where you know you and I we have having
an argument you say it's not gonna rain
tomorrow I said is going to rain
tomorrow things get a little bit heated
and I go no you know I think it's
probably not going to rain tomorrow odd
but I agree with you you know that that
that's okay and I kind of bail out of
the conversation and so so I think those
are the four kinds and if if I was an
escalator sort of red flags to look out
for are are the conversations are we
making mountains out of molehills you
know odd are we am i reflecting on a
conversation afterwards and thinking to
myself wasn't quite as much a big deal
as it seemed at the time you know to me
that would be a red flag and it's quite
difficult to spot in the moment because
these things can these things can build
quite quickly so that would be a
question I'd want to ask is you know am
I getting more heated more worked up
than this this issue really deserves
cancer Fanny yes yes it is this is this
kind of where I end up in a conversation
and and there's a risk here because and
and this in fact is what Piers Morgan
does is because Piers Morgan lacks the
analytical ability he's not greater
proving things with facts so he tries to
prove things with emotion
and he just goes to the thing of this is
really important this really matters
this is a moral issue and and that's how
he tries to be persuasive and and he is
persuasive you know that escalation is
is very it's kind of compelling and
particularly if you're a safety-first
and you don't like lots of emotion then
you're going to be inclined to sort of
back down so you know and I think the
one flag for an escalator would be if
you're looking back in a conversation
you go wasn't quite as much of a big
deal as it seemed at the time I think
for the the storyteller sometimes we can
look back and think what what actually
happened there you know what what was it
you know dude what was that about
and and at the time it seemed convincing
you know white flags and you don't
nobody likes white flags you know that
that's got to be wrong but as you say
you know then I look back and go well it
wasn't a bit cream and how big was it
and you know what's that that's you know
that I think those the storytellers is
that at the time it all seemed quite
plausible but then you look back and you
think you know it's almost like a dream
then you're gonna down to the brass
tacks of what was let over at the end of
the conversation
absolutely what was the number yeah not
foggiest yes yes yes and and then you
know and and to me that would be the
warning sign is you know we're all in
agreement and and and then it's like
well no and so so that's the storyteller
I think that the reason that you're all
in agreement is because you're kind of
not really agreeing about anything
you're everything about yes the world
yeah doesn't exist but everyone's got
this like everyone's granddad right is a
storyteller
everyone's granddad will speak for 30
minutes and he like yeah granddad but
then when he when he finishes you like
what the [ __ ] did he just say that's the
thing and and that's kind of the
strength and the weakness of the
storyteller and and that would be the
red flag it's like you know what what
was that all about
I think the analyst is you get left with
this feeling of you know that feeling
when you haven't persuaded someone all
the time yeah yes and and you know just
as I said that and you kind of
a bit of a delay and I was thinking have
I persuaded you you know had that this
is sort of awkward feeling like and and
then I'm going well should I escalate
this should I start telling a story what
should I do you know when because I
think there are only specific
circumstances where numbers are
persuasive and you know and and I'll
follow this track a little bit and I was
reading a book called the righteous mind
by a writer called Jonathan and hate and
and he says scientists even when they
wrong are prepared to change their mind
in a way that ordinary people are not ch
and he's got this paragraph where he
reflects on the fact that it is very
difficult to persuade ordinary people of
a view that they hold strongly with
scientists you know some scientists have
built entire careers on on a theory and
they may get to a point where they've
been working on this thing for 30 years
and eventually there's this kind of
incontrovertible argument and they go
not wrong you know yeah change my mind
yeah the reason why that is possible is
that scientists know the rules of
talking scientists cannot break the
rules of debate so trial scientists
cannot do things like cherry-pick they
cannot ignore evidence they cannot stick
their heads in the sand and pretend that
that they haven't heard an argument and
they can't abandon the rules of logic
and when you are held to those rigorous
processes sometimes you're forced to
change your mind because you've either
got the option of abandoned reason or
change your mind and scientists
generally would rather change their mind
an abandoned reason and surrender their
identity as scientists now normal people
are not explicitly trained in the
processes of reason but we all see
ourselves as reasonable people
we all and the thing is logic is not
that difficult you know amassing
evidence is not actually that difficult
and we all kind of know how it works
it's just that we're not always good at
applying it in particular situations and
what I have found is even when you're
talking with ordinary people working as
an analyst you can pull people back into
the conversation by saying but you
cannot deny that and be reasonable you
cannot ignore that piece of evidence and
be reasonable you cannot stick your head
in the sand and ignore that argument and
be reasonable so you're always injecting
this reminder to the person that they
see themselves as reasonable and they
are capable of reason so that I think is
the opportunity for the analysts to
become more persuasive is when they're
reminded of reason but you know that is
one of the red flags when you relying on
reason too much is you just go you know
I kind of said what I had to say but I
can see that this person was not moved
by my mom I mean if if all that it took
was facts and figures then we could just
email it on a spreadsheet and not bother
to have the conversation maybe that
right it's just it's just they're
thinking another problem that people
have is again the rules of the game are
so messy and because you have like in
the UFC
you got the Brazilian jiu-jitsu guy and
then you got the kickboxer and you got
the wrestler and blah blah because the
rules of the game for talking is so
messy not like science in science
there's quite sharp bright lines around
this is right this is wrong that is
statistically significant this isn't
this correlation there's not correlation
you don't have those objective metrics
you know you you picked a great example
they're basically mixed martial arts and
no-rules fighting and so you know I'm a
sports psychologist and about wow
there's about 15 years ago I worked with
the South African lightweight mixed
martial artist
champion and and at the same time I was
working with the all Africa judo
heavyweight champion this guy had not
been beaten in five years
he weighed a hundred and twenty
kilograms he's just like this awesome
human being but then I moved into the
world of MMA so judo obviously is very
strictly you know very strictly
rule-based and and governs and and then
MMA at the time was a bit of a Wild West
you know that the UFC he had I don't
think had emerged sure at least it
wasn't a big deal and and this guy used
to win fights by breaking people's arms
you know that that was just his
technique is he just like snap someone's
arm and then you know the fight was over
yeah and I used to go to his dojo
sometimes and and there were two
characters that I remember the one was
this butcher who weighed honestly this
guy weighed a hundred and thirty
kilograms of lean lean muscle
steroid it out to the max this is one of
the most terrifying human beings I've
ever met in my life
now I mean just consider the fact that
he's probably got roid rage like just
melting his brain he's got all of these
martial arts skills and the guy weighs
130 kilograms you know I mean that's
just a terror one if he wants you you're
his that's it I didn't even used to look
at him I just used to stay away safest
strategy yeah yeah and the other one was
a chiropractor who was a kind of
middleweight and he was the coach and
and he was describing I remember the one
time he was describing how you pinned
someone down on his on his stomach on
the floor and you start to punch him in
the back of the head
and obviously in UFC that rule is now
you can't do that anymore and that has
been one of the interesting things even
in mixed martial arts has been how much
more clear the rules have become over a
generation and if you go and watch UFC
one you know where they've got Gracie
and sumo wrestlers and karate guys you
know UFC one is a guy who he knocks over
a sumo wrestler and he just kicks him in
the head you know like as he's lying on
the ground to roll that's the one tooth
goes it's row if the other one gets
embedded in his foot and you know it's
kind of wild and but because in a rules
and and actually modern UFC is quite
rule governed you know they're quite
specific rules and the refs are quite
quick to jump in and and people know
what those rules are and this really is
my argument for talking is that that the
talking has become lawless but I believe
it would be improved it would become
more effective and would become safer if
we can apply some rules to it and that's
not impossible because as human beings
were generally quite good at applying
rules to complex processes
take football you're going to need to
have a lot of work done in people's
system too
[Music]
for them to slow everything down and be
incredibly deliberate for a long time
because yeah a deliberate conversation
is
enjoyable to a point yes but can become
a bit arduous after a while like when
you're consciously thinking about
everything you say the Sam Harris ISM
that he where he says that life is a
dream where you're constrained by the
reality outside of you in terms of how
your brain perceives it in that you
don't know what's going to happen next I
don't know the words that are going to
come out of my mouth until I say them
that's a very bizarre situation to be in
when you actually think about it I don't
know the next words that ago this
sentence and then this sentence and then
this sentence I don't know how many of
those this sentences I'm going to say
yeah yeah but if you're incredibly
deliberate you can choose to do that and
then the point is to use your planning
the planning you to instantiate these
new habits and then over time hope that
system one starts to pick that up and it
just occurs as a byproduct of now right
you don't you don't consciously have to
create your personality it just occurs
as a byproduct of you existing right
just manifests but it'll take a lot of
effort and humans evolutionarily our
heritage is to avoid effortful yasya
yeah yeah the path of least resistance
is always going to be there if you play
the fairer game if I play the I'm gonna
be real rigorous and I'm gonna be this
the other and then you start throwing
white flags at me all right well what am
i doing like I'm losing a conversation
that I was trying to you know there's so
many different messy things I I agree
that it would make for a much more
enjoyable conversational architecture
that we could all exist in what it
requires an awful like we can't get
people to have consensus about like tons
of stuff you're getting them some
consensus about the foundational
presuppositions that occur before we
have a conversation may also be
challenging absolutely yeah I you know I
completely agree and and you know the
point you're making about switching
between system one and system two that's
Rule four talk fast and slow and so much
of the talking that we
do you know you and I now it's quite a
lot of fast talking going on between the
two of us you know we're not planning as
you say we're not planning what it is
that we're going to say we kind of
hearing the words come out of our mouths
and and that's a great way to talk you
know imagine if we both just reading
pieces of paper at each other you know
that there would be that would be
terrible we would have lost something
but there are times when I need to be
able to jump in and and air a check and
that's the role of system to is to every
now and go nowhere where wait hang on
stop and and it's not a lot of the time
but if I can do it some of the time then
I've made an improvement and you know I
remember I I didn't actually put this
one in the book but the one time I used
to have this old Peugeot 307 and um
quality car was it in that gunmetal gray
well no darker darker no it wasn't it
was petrol was at the three dual petrol
and we used to had to get three kids in
the back and it wasn't running so well
and and you we were going to visit
friends and my wife said to me it's just
take the bus you know the car's not
working well I know and that's gonna be
fine you know there's going to be no
problem and and we drove to the friends
house and then we couldn't find parking
so we drove about 100 meters past the
friend's house and at that exact point
we could not be any further from home it
broke down and my wife turned to me and
she win you know we should have taken
the bus and and I remember I can't
remember the name of the movie I think
it's called Red October it's a submarine
movie and you know that their times were
in the submarine
everything's going bad and like their
red lights and people are running around
and it sounds going off and I was
thinking I'm in that movie you know they
are sirens going off this raid this
there's just bad stuff going on and and
and you know I I mean she was right
obviously but but that was a moment
where I think looking back had I been
able to slow things down and get a bit
of system and and I think it was such a
vivid sort of example and and you know I
was so clearly in the wrong
that I think it was a nice example to be
able to look back on and go well there's
a situation where slowing things down
could have been good but to come to your
next point which i think is also a
critical point and that is that this is
hard system to is harder than system one
and as human beings we seek efficiency
isn't you know it's not like any of us
have got masses of time and the day that
you know we we can spend having these
painstaking and deliberate rigorous
logical arguments but what I would say
to that
is that all of these arguments that we
have just about it's like do you think
the bricks had arguments with
fast-talking we didn't we took three
years and we still haven't solved that
we went round and round and round
this whole lockdown thing I'm not seeing
us progressing rapidly towards solutions
using the fast-talking idea even the
housework you know how long my household
has been discussing the dishwasher for
so don't underestimate how long and how
energy-sapping
these repetitive conversations can be
and sometimes it actually takes less
energy to invoke system to talk slowly
and rigorously and hopefully make some
actual progress for the mental model
funds out there that is direction over
speed incarnate for you if you are
moving in precisely the correct
direction it doesn't matter how fast or
how slow you know that you are making
small amounts of progress every single
day whereas if you focus on speed as
opposed to direction which is the
equivalent of efficiency over
effectiveness if you focus on speed you
can be going a hundred miles an hour in
exactly the wrong direction and then
turn around and go ah [ __ ] I've done all
of this work and actually my goal is now
further away from me okay and that
manifests itself in people who embed bad
habits that they think I'm gonna work
real real hard at doing this thing and
they end up having to then undo all of
this myelin that they've wrapped around
a ton of bad pathways yeah yeah really
and then start again but you have a
direction of a speed for the people
listening that love mental models so who
do you think is the best communicator as
some of the best communicators that have
ever lived well you know I'm biased
I'm South African Nelson Mandela and I
mean he's all right yeah yeah I I just
think I just think for a lot of reasons
you know I think in terms of his ability
to reach out I think in terms of his
ability to tell stories you know he was
an orator and and then just things like
his his body language his tone of voice
is facial expressions but I also think
in terms of his and you know rule three
is is most people are good competent and
worthy of respect and and I think if
there's one thing that I've kind of
learned or not necessarily learned but
just accepted
in this whole journey which has taken me
years it's possibly been rule three
most people are good competence and
worthy of respect and what that means is
that when we disagree I don't have the
easy solution that the reason why we're
disagreeing is because you just don't
know stuff you know our disagreement is
rooted and your ignorance or your
incompetence I've got to find a more
complex explanation but a better
explanation for why you and I disagree
and I think in terms of you know Nelson
Mandela I think he really understood
that you know he was able to take a
national tragedy that had lasted for
centuries and not locate the cause of it
in the moral failings or the badness of
a group of people
and he was able to see the good in
everybody in the country and I think
that is what enabled him to speak so
persuasively and and powerfully so you
know that that's me is a South African
and you know and that's me kind of
coming of age in in the time that he was
really talking to the country III think
you know I mean the other obvious answer
would be Winston Churchill and you know
Winston Churchill is known for will will
you know fight them on the beaches will
fight them and and that's wonderful
storytelling but I spent some time
reading through his speeches in detail
and and there's actually quite a quite a
precise logic that he's applying and the
other thing that he applies is that he
links cause and effect that he's not
just saying it's all going to be fine
we're gonna win he's talking about
things like ultimate sacrifice if we all
do our jobs
if we all apply ourselves then the
process will deliver a result so the
analysts seeping in a little bit there
that's a yes so while he is a wonderful
storyteller he's actually got this this
analytical understanding of the world
and this understanding of how processes
lead to outcomes and you know for me
that's what makes him a compelling
communicator as well
he worked incredibly hard at it I was
listening to really ryan holidays most
recent book not ego is the enemy
stillness is the key and he talks a lot
he delves into figures from history and
Churchill's one of them [ __ ] a man like
he Churchill did some graft like he
wrote he wrote like 40 books and he he
had this unbelievable routine this
walking and writing
and painting routine where he did he was
a king crow you know for someone that
was and then after the the war he was
kind of then just sort of left to one
side and then we kind of forgotten about
you in a bizarre sort of way which I
don't think many people know and I found
that I found that for he's a absolutely
fascinating individual and if anyone
that's listening has a good biography of
his that they could suggest I'd love to
get stuck into that Trump is he as much
of a master communicator as people say
you know he's obviously if it's in the
storyteller category and so you know
nobody would accuse him of being an
analyst
[Laughter]
[Music]
you're too precise it's yeah
and and no one would accuse him of being
a safety-first either you know he
doesn't shy away from that and the
opposite if anything he's like the anti
fragile safety first or he lays his feet
in even harder oh yeah yeah and that's
the escalation you know he just ramps it
up he every time he just goes up and up
and up so you've got you've got this
you've got the storyteller and an
escalator and he's extremely good at
that I think the quiz you would have to
ask if you to be critical of him is how
complex of the stories that he's telling
are these good stories are these stories
that that that that have a desired
effect because what is he telling these
stories for and one of the criticism you
know and and if you look at where the US
has gone in the three and a half years
of his presidency and I think in terms
of you could say standing in the world
the US does not have the same standing
in the world that it used to have and
and part of that is now you know he he
didn't sort of didn't start this
pandemic and but III think that would be
one hell of a conspiracy
[Music]
maybe we should that's it yeah you know
but but and I think it's fair to say
that the US response has has not been
widely widely admired and and and you
know in in terms of applying things like
rigor or mythology or consistent
approach or or things like adequate risk
you could say that they've been gaps in
in the way that he's led the country
so you know I think in terms of the
stories that he's telling some of the
stories are not actually the best
stories that you can tell you know if
you were to take Winston Churchill for
example if you were to take Nelson
Mandela they are all four storytellers
but they're telling different stories
they're telling stories about striving
for something about unity about
developing a a national identity he
doesn't tell those stories he tells
stories of of fear and division and and
selfishness and those are kind of easy
stories to tell because we've all got
switches for the easily tripped to
lowest winner the lowest hanging fruit
right the lowest common denominator yeah
yeah so you know he tells powerful
stories but in a way they're easy
stories to tell and so you know and
they're mean the other thing I would say
is he hasn't won a second election yet
you know he won one and he won it with
the lowest margin that you know
anybody's ever won an election I was
about yeah yeah yeah in in what was
about the three states or something
let's see how he gets on this time
because I think the real measure of how
effective he's been as a storyteller
will only emerge as we were saying
sometimes you can only evaluate the
story once it's been told and you know
he's not quite finished I don't know
whether it's the the US coughs and the
UK catches a cold or whatever it is um
man the the caliber of or maybe this is
a my disposition of taking more notice
of what's been going on in politics just
because I've been listening a little bit
more mm-hmm what about my trust in what
politicians say and what the media says
my view of the the delivery of the
things that they say in there's levels
of distrust that I've got that need to
be worked through here I don't know how
much of that is the
me being precluded from ever trusting
Trump because of what other people say
about him like even this like I need to
I need to strip away the bad
conversations from people that aren't
him to then look at the bad
conversations that he is having today do
not like it is difficult and you know if
there's one thing I think that we can
take away from this come on our
conversation today which hopefully has
been at least in part precise and and
easy to understand is that conversations
are challenging yes they require work
and I think because we just develop
language as a byproduct of being a kid
then we learn some words in school and
then we just think that we're going to
be able to get through the rest of our
life whilst you're not working at it
yeah you know
driving a car has a lower and upper
bound it has a lower bound on how bad
you can be the lower boundaries do you
cause road traffic accidents the upper
bound is essentially kind of once you're
above that it kind of doesn't matter
let don't matter if you're Colin McRae
or [ __ ] Michael Schumacher if you go
to the local shops it makes no
difference
however there's gradations of usefulness
and your value I would argue probably is
exponential not logarithmic it actually
goes like this and as you become as
you're the top 5% in the world to the
top 2% in the world to the top half a
percent in the world having
conversations and at being able to say
the things that are inside of your head
and articulate your words your
competitive advantage your ability to
enact change to convince others to be a
force for hopefully good in this world
yeah Inc is so much further ahead like
the difference between Joe Rogan as a
podcaster and the next best podcaster is
everything you know the difference
between me now and me two and a half
years ago when I started this show is
everything okay universes apart in a way
that I've still got tons a ways to go
but like I think that's a nice way to
look at it that people should be working
to be rigorous we've used the word
rigour a lot and I think that's a really
cool way to sort of talk about the
conversations yeah you should be precise
you should be rigorous with what you say
you should try and strive to be the best
conversationalist that you can because
that's how you compound wisdom right
that's how everything gets built yes yes
yes and as you say it's worth effort
now hopefully some people are gonna go
away from this and be better
conversationalist
if they want to pick up ten rules for
talking it will be linked in the show
notes below feel free to follow that
link on to Amazon and grab it on there
also you'll be supporting this podcast
and no extra cost to yourself and your
the stuff that you want to plug too many
other stuff people should go and check
out
no I'll leave it at that yeah you kind
of put me on the spot there and are you
on Twitter Instagram website blog any of
that stuff Twitter
Tim Harkness teen and yeah welcome yeah
welcome to to check that out but mainly
I think you know I spend a lot of time
working on that book so it's kind of
those are my ideas in there and that's
sort of me at the moment hey if this is
if this is a manifestation of you I
think it's a good good use of your time
mate and yeah that's a linked linked in
the show notes below go and check it out
if you want to have better conversations
I think we all could do with a little
bit of that I'll be probably as well a
lot of people that listen to this are
kind of fledgling podcasters I think
there's a lot of stuff in there that
I've stumbled upon during the time that
I've just been writing to people again
when you read something that reflects
reality do usually a pretty good
indication that it reinforces what
they're saying it reinforces what you're
saying as a rule of thumb yeah kind of
tells you going in the right direction
for sure yes so again if you want to
expedite some of your ability to have
conversations with people and grab this
Tim thank you so much fun well thank you
yeah and enjoyed enjoyed our
conversation saying that things are
imagined
[Music]